Narrator: NORTH PHILADELPHIA
BORN AND RAISED,
IN A GIANT VASE IS WHERE
HE SPENT MOST OF HIS DAYS.
THIS IS PHYSICS
AT ITS MOST MESMERIZING.
Narrator: GREG KENNEDY IS
THE ONLY JUGGLER ON EARTH
TO NAIL NINE BALLS OF LIGHT
IN A GIGANTIC CONE.
THIS GUY DOESN'T
EVEN LIKE JUGGLING.
BUT NO ONE WILL LET HIM
OUT OF THE CONE.
Narrator: WE'RE IN PHILLY
TO ENTER THE CONE ZONE
AND SHED SOME LIGHT
ON GREG'S CAPTIVATING SKILLS.
I'VE ALWAYS LIKED
TO CHALLENGE MYSELF.
SOME OF THE THINGS YOU MIGHT
SEE ME DO IN THE CONE
IS NOT SOMETHING THAT TOOK
A MONTH OR A YEAR.
I'VE BEEN WORKING ON SOME OF
THOSE PATTERNS FOR A DECADE NOW.
I'M COMING UP
WITH WHOLE NEW THINGS
THAT NOBODY EVER DREAMED OF.
AND FOR ME, THAT'S PART
OF BEING HUMAN,
PART OF BEING ALIVE.
Narrator:
WHO WANTS TO LIFT THE LID
ON THIS BEWILDERING BALL SHOW?
GREG'S SKILL IS IN HOW
HE THROWS THOSE BALLS.
HE DOESN'T LET THEM BOUNCE,
BUT INSTEAD ROLLS THEM SMOOTHLY
'ROUND THE INSIDE OF THE CONE.
ONCE THEY'RE ON THE WALL
AND TRAVELING,
THE CENTRIFUGAL EFFECT KEEPS
THE BALLS STUCK TO THE WALL.
IT'S TRYING TO TRAVEL
IN A STRAIGHT LINE,
BUT THE SHAPE OF THE CONE
IS MOVING IT IN A CURVE.
Oluseyi:
AND THIS MEANS AT ALL TIMES,
THE BALL IS PUSHING ON THE WALL
AND THE WALL IS PUSHING BACK
ON THE BALL.
SO IF I TAKE A BALL
AND I THROW IT HORIZONTALLY
AND WITH THE RIGHT ENERGY,
IT'LL STAY...
IN A PERFECT CIRCLE.
I CAN ALSO DO THAT DOWN LOW.
BUT I'LL HAVE TO THROW
WITH A LITTLE LESS ENERGY.
I CAN TAKE THAT BALL
AND I CAN THROW IT DOWNWARDS
WITH A LOT OF ENERGY...
AND IT WILL COME BACK UP.
I CAN ALSO THROW IT UPWARD...
AND IT'LL GO DOWN AND BACK UP.
Narrator:
BUT HOW DO GREG'S BALLS
GO DOWN AND BACK UP AGAIN?
EACH BALL IS BEING FORCED
TO FOLLOW A CURVED PATH,
WHICH MEANS IT'S GETTING
ANGULAR MOMENTUM.
Oluseyi: ANGULAR MOMENTUM
IS A CONSERVED QUANTITY.
THAT MEANS THAT UNLESS SOME
OUTSIDE FORCE ACTS ON THE BALLS,
THE ANGULAR MOMENTUM
WILL REMAIN THE SAME.
ANGULAR MOMENTUM
DEPENDS ON THREE THINGS --
THE MASS OF THE BALL...
Oluseyi: ITS DISTANCE
FROM THE CENTER OF ROTATION,
WHICH IN THIS CASE
IS THE CENTRAL AXIS OF THE CONE,
AND HOW FAST
THE BALL IS MOVING.
Arney: IF YOU CHANGE
ONE OF THESE THINGS,
THE OTHER TWO HAS TO CHANGE
SO THAT THE TOTAL
IS ALWAYS THE SAME.
Pampena: BECAUSE EACH BALL
IS MAKING ITS WAY
DOWN THE CONE DUE TO GRAVITY,
IT MEANS THE TIGHTNESS
OF ITS CURVE IS GETTING SMALLER.
THAT FORCES THE BALL
TO GET FASTER
JUST TO KEEP ANGULAR MOMENTUM
THE SAME.
THE FASTER EACH BALL GETS,
THE GREATER THE CENTRIFUGAL
EFFECT ACTING UPON IT,
WHICH IS PUSHING IT OUTWARDS.
BUT BECAUSE IT'S IN A CONE,
IT EFFECTIVELY GOES UPWARDS.
Narrator:
IT'S CIRCUS WITH SCIENCE.
Kennedy:
OVER TIME, AS I'VE GOTTEN OLDER,
I FIGURED OUT IT WAS
GONNA BE BETTER FOR ME
TO CONTINUE JUGGLING LESS
WITH MY BODY
AND A LITTLE BIT
MORE WITH MY MIND.
MY CONTRIBUTION AT THIS POINT
IS ACTUALLY EXPANDING
THE REALM OF JUGGLING
AND CREATING NEW CONCEPTS.
AND, IN A LOT OF WAYS, I THINK
THAT'S GONNA BE MY LEGACY.
Narrator: GREG,
YOU TOTALLY OWN THE CONE.